That's not full screen.
But it's close.
Well, you get a whole experience there.
Some of my desktop background.
Okay.
Cool.
Hello, everyone.
So, I'll start off by telling you a quick
story.
There was a rabbi who also would give sermons
from a pulpit kind of like this on Saturday
mornings.
And he gave the best sermons.
They were† they rocked the house!
And they were lasting sometimes 15 minutes,
20 minutes.
Sometimes if they're really good, a half hour.
Really get into it, the spirit was moving
him.
And people loved it.
One Saturday morning at the reception after
services one of the members came up to him,
for lack of a name, call him Mr.†Cohen.
And Mr.†Cohen says I run a daytime talk
show.
I would love you to be on the talk show.
Today, it was so inspiring, I think it will
just move the audience.
Can you come on to the talk show on Tuesday
morning?
And the rabbi says, I guess I'll do that.
Sure.
Why not.
But there's only one problem, Mr.†Cohen.
He says you speak so powerfully, but the slot
is only for two minutes.
Two minutes.
It's a TV show.
It's snippets.
And the rabbi says, no problem.
I can bring that down to two minutes.
And Cohen said if you can do that for the
talk show, can you do that every week?
I know I'm the penultimate talk before lunch,
but I don't know about you, but in my community,
food and lunch is a big deal.
I understand if your stomach says you're hungry
and try to be concise and keep to 25 minutes.
Although, a fair warning, rabbis can be a
little verbose.
We can be a little longwinded, but I will
try and keep it down.
So, the talk for today is preparing for the
technical interview.
And I think it's a really important one for
people who, like me, came into coding, came
into this field from backgrounds that were
not the traditional backgrounds.
Meaning I didn't graduate with a computer
science degree, a logic degree, a math degree.
I majored in psychology and minored in political
science and a lot of theology.
How do you prepare for these conversations
when you don't come from that place?
So, just first, a little bit about who I am.
So, I† this work† I was born and raised
in San Diego.
It's a beautiful city at the very edge of
California right on the border of Mexico.
A great childhood.
A lot of time at the beach.
A lot of fun.
And I also was a bit of a nerd in San Diego.
And so, I helped to create a couple meetings.
This is from 2000, I think, this website.
This was the San Diego 2600 meeting.
Does anybody remember 2600 Magazine?
I see a hand.
2600 Magazine.
2600 Magazine was like a hacker magazine.
It was cool in the '90s, early 2000s.
And they had like meetings throughout the
world.
I created the San Diego chapter of the 2600
meeting.
This was our website.
And it just recently got a facelift.
Capital W, capital S. That tells you so much
about the time.
I was up there, I was Skalore.
I liked ska music.
I was a major nerd.
And in the 2600 meeting we created Tor:Con.
A computer info sec conference.
It was started in 1999.
It's in the 20th year next year.
And now, now there's three, San Diego, Seattle,
TorCamp in Washington State, five days.
And TorWorld, a hacker cruise in Antarctica.
I was about 15 or 16 when we created this
conference.
I many parents had to sign off on the room
reservations at the UCSD Price center where
we had the event.
It's now at the convention center.
This was sent to listservs.
This was 1999, southern California's only†
all caps!
Comprehensive interactive, a comprehensive,
interactive and enjoyable conference to the
western United States to make people aware
of the importance of computer security.
And it cost a whopping 35 bucks to come to
the conference.
Now it's a little more expensive in the 20th
year.
But it was $35.
And so, after that, from my childhood in San
Diego and being a bit involved in computers
I moved to New York.
So, from the sunny San Diego to New York.
And that's what it looks like all year if
you have never been there.
Believe me.
That's New York City.
And I went to New York to a small liberal
arts Jewish college in Queens.
In the neighborhood of Flushing, New York.
Anybody been to Flushing?
Flushing is awesome.
It's one of the most diverse neighborhoods
I think in the United States.
It's an awesome place.
But I went to the opposite of a diverse experience.
Allmale, ultra-orthodox Jewish college.
From 9:00 in the morning to 6:00 at night
in religious studies and 6:00 to 9 p.m. in
college.
And 911 back in religious studies.
So, I had a lot of free time.
I was hanging out in New York all the time.
I barely left from the dorm to the school
back to the dorm to the school.
And a couple years into my college experience,
a magazine in San Diego reached out to me
for this really tacky article.
And I just want to show one quick quote about
what I was actually going.
Graphics, what people think you're doing versus
what you're actually doing in life.
So, then this article from 2003, they're like,
my mind wandered off to Ben Greenberg having
really gone to school.
Maybe he hadn't!
Oh, no.
But this was what I was actually doing.
I was studying all day, a book of† many,
many books of Jewish thought and law written
in Aramaic, a wonderful Hebrew language spoke†in
Syria and in the Jewish community.
Studied that.
And once I was a rabbi, I was doing stuff
like this.
Talking about matzah and holding it up.
Every rabbi has this.
It was important.
I was leading this in Chicago on the topic
of gun violence.
If you're not from the States, it's regrettably
a major issue.
I was at that time a community organizer in
Chicago.
That's what I was actually doing.
I wasn't doing anything else.
I had actually gone to the school.
And fast forward ten years and I decided I
wanted to have a change in pace.
And I at my ten-year mark in my career I said,
you know, I could either keep on doing this
for life.
I could go back to being what I really love,
which is a nerd.
And I went to Flatiron School.
A boot camp in New York City.
It's now part of a reworked family, via international
coworking space.
And at the school I met a lot of people like
me.
I met graphic designers and musicians and
artists and teachers and lawyers and sales
people, and, yes, rabbis.
In fact, my colleague at the company I work
at now who is a developer who sits right behind
me is also a former rabbi who went to the
Flatiron School and we went together.
We're not the only ones.
In fact, we have a whole Slack channel just
for rabbis turned developers.
The conversations are fascinating.
It's a mix of Hebrew and English and Yiddish
all the time.
It's awesome.
If you want to know coding terminology in
Yiddish, we can talk later.
And we transitioned to coding for a lot of
reasons.
We did it because we love the ability to create.
Coding was incredibly technical.
It's a highly, highly technical field.
It's an incredibly creative field.
And for those of us who come from other creative
professions, whether it's art or somewhere
else, you get to exercise that part of your
brain all the time as a programmer.
In different ways, in totally different modalities.
But you still get to create all the time.
And we also love it because of jobs.
There's a lot of jobs as a programmer.
New York City, there are tons of programming
jobs.
It is awesome.
When you have a family to support, it's even
better.
And we love it because of the excitement of
learning.
You never stop learning as a programmer.
Actually, reminds me of my education.
It never ends, every time you see a word,
what does it mean?
Another JavaScript framework, how can I pick
up that?
It never stops.
And we love it because of jobs.
Did I say that already?
I think I did.
We love the fact that we can make an impact.
Working at whatever kind of company you work
at.
I work at a financial services company, if
you work at a nonprofit, you can make a difference.
When it's a good day, not every day is a good
day, but on a good day, you can say I have
done something.
Quantitatively done something.
I started here and ended here.
And there's something powerful about that.
And we love jobs.
And the work cultures.
My car had an issue, I went to the coffee
shop and somewhere else and wasn't home.
And those who work remotely, I'm only a little
jealous of you.
We love the fact you can take your work with
you.
And, of course, there's some down sides to
that as well.
But the idea that you don't have to be tethered
to a desk all day or all night.
And we also have jobs.
Yes.
And did I mention jobs?
Jobs are awesome.
And I put that there several times not only
to be funny but because, yes, this is a great
career for people looking for something exciting,
something you can make an impact, something
with remote work culture, and you can create
and a lot of potential to actually take care
of yourself, take care of your family and
to be economically secure which in this world
we really can't take for granted.
And so, in the boot camp process, first comes
the learning.
And the learning is awesome.
It's hard to describe how awesome the learning
is.
You start from†nothing† I mean, the last
time I coded was in Perl.
And JavaScript was not really a thing in 1997.
And so, you start learning everything anew,
essentially.
And it never ends.
It's like an endless sea of functions and
methods.
And I like the gems of Ruby and the snakes
of Python and all these things and it's so
awesome.
And then when you're ready, whether you finished
a boot camp or you're selftaught and feel
like you're ready to get out into the job
market.
Polish the resume and turn the nontech experience
into a resume that won't get thrown out by
the filters.
Polish the resume.
The cultural interviews.
Why do you want to work here?
Because you want to pay me.
And you get past the cultural conversations
and then you get to the white board.
And the white board can be absolutely terrifying
if you're anyone.
Anyone.
Whether you come from a CS background or you
don't come from a CS background.
Whether you have done this for a long time
or the first day, it's a terrifying experience.
And it's even more so, I don't know your experience
if you come from a CS background.
I know my experience.
If you don't, it's a nightmare.
There's multiple points why it's challenging.
One is at the boot camp, whatever boot camp
you went to, chances are you learned how to
do things.
Maybe you learned React, JavaScript, you learned
a Ruby is a fun one to learn at boot camps.
You learn how to code, right?
But you don't necessarily learn the algorithms.
You don't learn about data structures.
You don't learn about the things that you
would learn if you go to a fouryear traditional
CS degree.
And yet oftentimes in front of the white board
and all you have is that marker and the eraser
and a bunch of eyes intently staring at you
and watching you.
They're asking you what kind of questions?
They're often asking you questions about data
structures.
Or they're asking algorithmic questions.
They're not asking you to create a React component
on the white board.
They're not asking you to create a function
that does X, Y or Z.
Even the fun ones, palindrome functions.
Those are fun.
They're not asking those.
They're asking typically algorithmic questions.
Which you don't prepare for.
What you do all day when you're not interviewing,
I had in my backpack a tiny white board and
I took everywhere.
In between picking up kids from daycare or
at the coffee shop, I had the wait board out
and I was practicing and practicing and practicing
and practicing algorithmic questions.
And I had that big book.
You know the big book I'm talking about?
Cracking the coding interview book.
And it simultaneously freaked me out and freaked
me out.
Basically.
And I just practiced all† I looked a little
crazy, you know, sitting in Starbucks with
a white board writing things that kind of
looked like English but not really English.
What is that guy doing?
Do I need to be worried?
And so that's what I did.
What I want to do with our time, the remaining
time is talk about how we can go from this
to this in this experience.
And I'm not going to solve it.
And it's not necessarily going to go from†
all the way from this all the way to that.
But hopefully go from like a total nightmare
to not as freaked out might be the goal.
And these things come from my own experiences.
Just things that helped me to prepare.
General principles.
So, we're going to talk about some of these
general principles.
And then we're going to apply them to one
example.
A relatively easy example, but an example
we can cover in the time we have.
So, our first principle is to know your strengths.
Know what you're good at.
So, if you come to this field with a liberal
arts degree, it's not like you come from ground
zero.
You have skills.
They may not be the same exact skills or you're
not necessarily strong in the exact skills
as someone who came from a CS background has,
but you have skills they might not have as
well.
If you understand the skills you have, you
are strong, you can translate the problems
into a language that resonates with you.
Into a language that speaks to you.
So, for example, which one of these makes
more sense to you?
This?
Does that make sense to anyone?
I see a couple head nods.
Or this?
Does that make sense to anyone?
So, this makes absolutely no sense to me.
That might as well be like Greek or something
like.
And no offense to people from Greece, it may
as well be Greek.
This doesn't make sense at first, but I know
English.
And I know English really well.
And so, I can actually parse this and translate
it into something that's meaningful.
The negation of a dysfunction is the conjunction
of the negations.
Like the opposites.
Something that's together is the conjunction
of something that's not the same.
It's the law, a logic principle.
Oftentimes white board interviews are presented†
the challenge is presented from somebody who
comes from a world where this makes a lot
more sense than this.
And so, the question with the unintended bias,
the biases that we all carry around in ourselves
on a plethora of things, whatever they are,
they are biases for how we learn.
And we will present to someone who is interviewing
a certain way a formulation of a question
thinking it's an easier way to understand
it.
But ultimately, for the person interviewing,
that might not be the way thing.
And it's okay if neither of these made sense.
It's okay.
It's complicated.
But in general, people with a more technical
proclivity, we like to limit the number of
words.
So, it's about being lazy.
Being a lazy programmer.
Being as efficient as possible with the minimum
amount of typing you can possibly type.
Like, if I can have a shortcut in my IDE to
put a whole function there, that's amazing.
I want to do that.
And I want to make sure if I can do this in
15 words or 15 key strokes, but do it in three?
I'll do it in three.
Readability is an issue as well.
But limit the number of words.
Liberal arts people like to think about how
we can turn one word into a sentence, how
to make one sentence into a paragraph and
a paragraph into an essay and an essay into
a dissertation.
That's what you do.
Rabbis talk in the sermons, priests, Imams,
we like to talk about the idea over and over
again.
I want to make sure you got what I'm talking
about.
If I say it one time, two times, three times,
that's not enough for you.
I need to say it four or five times.
You over there, eight times.
I need to see the idea so many times.
And at the end of it, you think you're going
to get the job and you're like, what the heck
just happened?
Does he think I'm an idiot?
But it's because we're very verbose.
And I'm being verbose right now talking about
it a lot.
I'm demonstrating it.
That's very important to be able to translate
into a language that speaks for you.
Principle number two is every building starts
with the first brick.
Every complex idea, every complex idea is
ultimately a collection of smaller ideas.
And the smaller ideas can be broken down into
smaller ideas.
It's kind of like a multidimensional array.
You can break down ideas and unpack them and
unpack them until you get to the first foundational
idea.
And then† so, you're presented with the
building.
The problem is the building.
And your job, if this is helpful for you†is
to deconstruct the building.
Thank you.
To deconstruct the building and build it back
up again.
So, if you deconstruct it and build it back
up again, that can help you understand more.
And lastly, principle number three, interviewing
is iterative.
It's an iterative process.
At first, I was horrible at it.
I'm still pretty bad at it.
I don't know why I'm talking about it.
But interviewing is an iterative process,
and if you understand your failures and opportunities
to grow, you'll get better.
This is a quote from a rabbi in Brooklyn in
the 20th century.
The righteous person falls seven times and
rises again.
Because the knowledgeable are aware that the
essence of rising is because of your seven
falls.
It's not in spite of your seven falls, it's
because you fell.
And you don't need a rabbi or a priest or
an imam to tell you this, but look at the
handsome guy?
A nice face.
He wrote win at losing: How our biggest setbacks
can lead to the biggest gains.
At Barnes and Noble, it's an entire half a
bookstore, how to win by losing.
And ultimately, there's a lot of truth to
that.
And so, let's take an example.
Binary search.
So, good example.
It's a relatively simple example.
We can apply these principles to it.
What is it?
Applying principle number one.
Know your strengths.
Move.
There we go.
So, binary is not a word that is in the lexicon
of liberal arts folks.
Break down the word binary, it's essentially
one or the other.
Zero or one, on or off.
One or the other search.
A method of searching one or the other place.
It's similar to finding your name at a conference.
If your name is like mine, Greenberg, not
going to start at the beginning or end of
the table, but relatively near the beginning.
You landed at D or F and narrow it down.
That's a binary search.
Applying that one brick at a time.
It's a list, and I have with the ordered value.
Something I find that's closest to it, look
through the section.
Is it there?
Yes.
It is there.
Then we party.
It's awesome!
It's there!
We're so happy!
Is it not there?
No.
Then at least we have limited the range of
values and we can make two new sections.
And then until we found it.
And we found it.
Then we are so happy.
And in fact, psychologists tell us looking
at cute puppies makes us happy.
Feel the serotonin?
It's awesome.
So, we're very happy.
We looked at a cute puppy.
And interviewing is iterative.
So, you're at the white board.
You don't know what to do.
The one thing not to do at the white board
is to freeze.
Write something down.
It may not be the perfect thing or the best
thing bub at least it's something.
So, for me, and I know I'm a relatively new
developer, but this is how fast JavaScript
moves.
For me, it's easier to think in ES5 than ES6.
I jump to ES5 and interviews might want to
see you declare a function with ES6 syntax.
It's hip and cool to know the newest stuff.
It's easy.
But I don't want to freeze at the board and
do nothing.
I'll declare a function.
I know I need items, I need a value.
I declare a function.
Then I'm going to declare some variables.
And then write the rest of it.
And it's not perfect.
It's totally not perfect.
That doesn't take the case of edge cases,
doesn't factor in those issues.
And it might not be super-fast.
It's not the best function in the world, but
it gets the job done.
And then when you get the job done, you get
to do the best part of the white board interview.
You get to talk about your code.
Talking about the code in the interviews,
you get an opportunity to think about it,
out of the stress of writing it and you can
go back and start making it better.
Because can't it†be made better?
Yes, we can.
We can make it better by making it into ES6.
And we can use the bitwise or zero operator
which is, again, not a perfect thing either,
but from a performance perspective, it is
faster.
Take into at least one edge case.
That if the value is less than the first thing
and more than the last, exit out.
Don't need to switch the search.
We do a little bit to at least make it a little
better.
And can we make that better?
Of course, we can make that better.
Are we going to do it right now?
No!
Because I got one minute left.
But we can totally make that better and keep
on improving.
Because interviewing is iterative.
Interviewing, coding, learning, growing, living,
are all† if this was forward is iterative.
All this stuff.
Your life is iterative.
The process is iterative.
So, to recap, three principles.
Know what your brain power is.
Take the building apart one brick at a time
and rinse, wash and repeat.
And ultimately, one quote, I have to because
I am a rabbi still.
Quote from Jewish tradition around 200CE.
This means it's not your responsibility to
finish the work, but neither are you free
to desist from it.
The thing that is both amazing about programming
is the never ending journey.
But if you see the journey as actually the
destination and not continue to get freaked
out that you're never going to end, then it
becomes a process of not only a freaking out
moment on interviews, but actually becomes
an enjoyable experience.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]